ce qui fait bondir aussi mathieu
commencé à courir suis là j'avais jamais
répondu parce que j'étais persuadé qu'
on juge la qualité d'un homme à la
qualité de ses ennemis c'est vous dire
si j'avais pas envie de la voir comédie
mais franchement il est en plus si on
disait vraiment la vérité j'avais dit
juste qu effectivement quelqu'un quand
idée de quand il dit dans l'émission
tiens ta femme et qui fait ça pour moi
c'est quand même menaçant pour les
femmes mais au-delà de ça il s'en est
pris à nrj12 aux anges en disant qu'on
vous à l'époque que de la merde pardon
pour être un petit peu voilà cavaliers
sauf que ce qui nie pas et du coup je
vais le dire comme ça ce sera une fois
pour toute c'est que à l'époque ce
garçon faisait des pieds des mains faire
les émissions qu'il a fait le casting
des ligers il n'a pas été pris et
qu'après me demandais si je pouvais
vraiment l'aider pour être pris dans ce
genre d'émission donc toutes celles
qu'il a critiqué il a voulu les faire
manque de bol il n'a pas été pris comme
quoi une nageuse dans le petit peu le
sens encore des qualités de la valeur et
non finalement et maintenant ils me qui
me lâche à chaque fois qu'il parle il
parle de moi il n'y a pas quelqu'un il
n'est pas quelqu'un dans sa vie pour
s'occuper un peu il ne vit que la télé
réalité il ne fait que ça il refait les
koh lanta xxx fois il ne vit que de ça
lâche moi sérieux alors qu'ici j'ai
trouvé une vraie famille aux autres